all right for more let's bring in
Florida Congressman Mike Waltz member of
the House Foreign Affairs committee what
do you think about that using the our
national parks now to house these
migrants yeah Sandra the the hypocrisy
here is Rich on multiple levels I mean
President Biden just dedicated a new
National Monument National Park out in
Arizona ostensibly to preserve and
protect those pristine lands uh for
future generations and when it comes to
any type of new energy exploration
denied not allowed any kind of mining uh
for our economy denied not allowed but
suddenly it's okay to put tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants on there
without appropriate sewage facilities
without appropriate living conditions
then that suddenly that's going to be
fine so I mean that is Rich with
hypocrisy the whole Sanctuary City uh I
narrative is completely blown up uh for
for the left and then my question is
this is supposedly a temp temporary
solution with temporary housing how
temporary is temporary and how far is
this going to go are we going to see
tent cities and Yellowstone and yose
next uh there's no plan it's out of
control yeah I mean there's no talk
about that a time limit Governor hokel
uh said she'll fully reimburse the city
for the leasing of Floyd Bennett Field
um but when and how for how long for how
long um okay so Democrats on the hill
just spoke to our own Hill vaugh uh we
just we just heard from uh Senate
Judiciary Republicans for quite a while
on the border Hillary was able to talk
to some Democrats on the hill about the
situation at our Southern border listen
to what they had to say
Congressman at what point does this
become an invasion of our country well I
I would never use that word not an
invasion this is not some uh uh pests
these are human beings and that's the
way they need to be treated people
people are breaking the rules paying a
criminal organization to do so to get to
the front of the line does that concern
you have you ever been to the border
before to see what's happening yes I
have I've spent a lot of time at the
border yeah you didn't talk with the
right people apparently cuz your
information your questions based on uh
you know your questions are kind of off
base didn't talk to the right people
Hank Johnson tells her what was your
response when you heard that you know
that's just that's sad uh and they can
no longer stick their in the sand just
women and girls alone multiple uh
International NOS say 30 to 40% and do
the math on that of women and girls are
sexually assaulted raped and sold into
human trafficking uh the cartels are
running our border they control 30% of
Mexico they're heavily armed uh we have
to take action here and listen the thing
that is really blowing up their just
denial of the situ
is that people are feeling it in New
York and in Chicago and in cities all
over the United States it's not just if
you don't watch uh Fox News you don't
see it they're seeing it every time they
walk out their door now uh and it can no
longer be ignored all right Congressman
I appreciate you joining us um and again
reiterating these are live images coming
in every single minute that we're
watching this this is more and more
people coming over that border Eagle
Pass Texas uh middle of the day one :30
Central Time there Congressman thank you
for joining us appreciate it thank you
I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis